one of Animal Crossing new horizons
biggest new features is island designer
and app for the in-game nook phone that
lets you terraform your island to your
liking in this video I'll show you how
to unlock the island designer app and
how to use it effectively first up let's
unlock this thing island designer is a
later game feature so there's a few
steps you need to take over at least two
weeks of playtime in order to unlock it
you need to have unlocked the resident
services building and begun tom nooks
project Kay assignment which requires
you to build the campsite invite the
first camper to live on your island
build three housing plots following his
instructions get three villagers to move
into those houses one per day and get
your island to a three star rating
project Kay will take quite a few days
to complete plus the time and effort it
takes to decorate your Island and
improve your rating luckily as long as
you plant flowers and trees and put some
furniture here and there you should be
able to get to three stars pretty easily
once you've improved your population
numbers the day after you've reached
three stars Tom Nook will give you the
island designer app on your nook phone
at first you'll only have access to the
path to land two types of paths grass
and dirt but you can unlock more path
options the water scaping tool and the
cliff construction tool with new clients
each additional path type costs two
thousand Nick miles with the exception
of the custom design path which costs
twenty three hundred this will let you
use any custom design as a path you can
unlock each of the additional path
styles at the Nook stop machine in
resident services you can unlock the
ability to water scape and separately
the ability to build cliffs at any time
after you've received the island
designer app each permit cost six
thousand miles and can be redeemed at
the Nook stop machine in resident
services before you really get going
with island designer you'll want to
familiarize yourself with all the tools
the app itself includes a manual that
will walk you through the basics
each tool is operated with a and you can
use the plus button to switch between
permits and path types when you're using
the path tool pressing a on a plain
grassy area will build a path and then
pressing a again will remove it you can
also use the grass tool to remove paths
once you have a few path tiles next to
each other pressing a on them will first
round the path and then you'll have to
press a again to remove it fully you can
use this to create rounded edges and
various shapes for example to make
circles on the ground put for path tiles
next to each other in a square
then hit a on each of them again to
round them out four hearts do a bigger
3x3 square with one corner missing and
then round out the side nearest to that
empty corner you can only dig into dirt
dark dirt and sand paths and you can
plant flowers and trees on those paths
to all other paths are more solid but
you can still place items on top of them
like you would grass dirt or sand keep
in mind that fossils will only appear on
grass so it's not recommended that you
totally cover your islands and paths
regular custom designs mostly work like
any other path but unlike regular paths
you can remove them at any time using Y
which is likely to be an accident and
can be frustrating also custom designs
do lay flush with one another even if
they're different because of this you
can make a more complex path using
several different designs and use the
plus button to switch between them as
you go also if your custom design has at
least one transparent pixel you can
layer that design over the standard
paths and it'll conform to the existing
path shape this way you can round up the
edges of your custom designs like you
would the regular paths you just have to
put down and shape a regular path first
and then put your design over it and if
you change a custom design any path
you've put down using that design will
change with it this could make it easy
to update your paths without having to
redo all of them but make sure you're
editing the right ones for water scaping
pressing a on land will dig a trench for
water pressing a again will fill up the
trench and as with paths if you have a
few tiles of water next to each other
pressing a will first round out the
edges and then when pressed again remove
the water entirely water escaping is the
most finicky of the island designer
tools and it definitely takes practice
for example to round out a sharp corner
you'll have to place your character a
bit back from the edge your character
can hop across any water feature that's
one or two tiles wide with this in mind
you can create land bridges across
rivers without fully dividing the river
you can just fill in a piece of land in
the middle of the river and jump across
it villagers won't be able to cross
rivers without bridges though also make
sure you leave enough river to fish in
normally if you care about fishing
you'll want at least some river on a
cliff section in order to catch cliff
top only fish and you'll want any river
you hope to fishin to be a normal width
three or four tiles so you can get your
bobber wherever you need it to go
Cliff's are built and destroyed from the
level below them and like with anything
else you can round them if you have
multiple cliff pieces next to each other
you can build up to three tiers of
cliffs on top of one another but you
won't be able to climb up the third tier
and you can't build new tiers right up
to the edge of the previous tier meaning
you can't make big cliff walls villagers
won't be able to go up cliffs without an
incline so keep this in mind when
placing villager houses on cliffs to
build waterfalls you need to be up on
the cliff you'd like the waterfall to go
down you can then use the water escaping
tool to build the waterfall at the edge
keep in mind that you need to fill in
the waterfall first before you can
destroy the cliff it's on that's
everything you need to know about
terraforming in Animal Crossing new
horizons if you have any terraforming
tips be sure to share them in the
comments below and for more animal
crossing guides stay tuned to game spot
[Music]